has the theme of combinatorics and
randomness we have lots of papers that
cover that talk about very fundamental
problems but at the same time have
general results that
can be useful in many other areas
and we're starting with a paper on um
card testing then we have a couple of
papers on random bots we have a paper on
sampling and distributions so these are
all very general and very clean results
that a tcs audience should appreciate
and understand
and it may just be that one of the
lemons that we talked about is just the
thing you need to finish your own
research project
so let's start the first speaker is boaz
manuhin from wiseman
and he will talk about um
card dressing with limited memory so can
you share your slides
right so thanks a lot for the
presentation and for the introduction
um
so i'll be telling about uh keep this
card in mind card guessing with limited
memory which demonstrates the power of
adaptive adversaries in stream this is a
joint work with
monino
so card guessing is played by two
players a dealer and a guesser
the dealer begins the game with the deck
that consists of end cards
in each turn the dealer draws a card and
the guesser tries to guess it
the card is then revealed and discarded
so it can no longer be played
and the guesser gets a point for each
correctly guest cards each correctly
guest card
and
what we're interested in is how many
correct guesses did the guests reviewed
and since the game is random by nature
we're interested in the expected number
of correctly guessed cards
with a guesser with perfect memory can
just keep track of all cards that still
reside in the deck and guess from them
just in every turn guess the card that's
the result in the deck
um on the first turn that gets to be
correct with probability one over n on
the second with one over n minus one and
so on until the last card which the
guesswork can identify correctly
uh for certain and by linearity of
expectation we get that the number of
correct guesses is expected to be the
harmonic sum which is roughly lan n
on the other extreme a guesser with no
memory at all
um the best such a guesser can achieve
would result in a correct guess with
probability one over n in every term
so again the linearity of expectation uh
we expect a single correct yes
but
a memoryless guess we can also get a
correct guess for certain by simply
repeating the same guess over and over
again
since
each card must appear exactly once in
the game that guess who would be correct
once and only once
these two examples are taken from
textbook on algorithms by kleinberg and
tardash and they demonstrate that with n
bits of memory
uh
we can achieve one n with zero bits of
memory we can achieve a single correct
guess but what we're interested in is
what happens in between
and our answer is that it depends much
on the dealer
so we consider three kinds of dealers
the first dealer we consider is a random
shuffle one that dealer shuffles the
deck properly at the beginning of the
game and draws cards one by one
this is equivalent to drawing at random
in every turn or to sample a random
permutation pi and draw the card pi i in
turn i
the second dealer we consider is a
static dealer that dealer pre-arranges
the deck at the beginning of the game
since that dealer may be somewhat
familiar with the guesser so in order to
fail him uh that dealer fixes the deck
in advance and but once the game begins
the deck remains as it is so
the order cannot change mid-game
the
third dealer we consider is an adaptive
one
that dealer draws cards thoughtfully in
an adversarial manner
uh in response to how the guests are
played so far
as for the guesser we assume that
the guesser has memory of size m and
some random bits
and it is made of two functions a card
guessing function and state transition
function
the card guessing function receives
the memory state and randomness and
produces some guess
and the state transition functions also
the function also receive a card
the last drawn card to produce the next
memory state
so for example one very simple technique
is to concentrate on a subset of m cards
with embeds of memory and pretend as if
the deck consists only of these cards
um
since
these m cards must appear at some point
and
by tracking them and guessing a card
from this set that doesn't appear
um
basically we get perfect score
if the deck
contained m cards so we get one
m so the guessing function is just to
guess a card that did not appear and the
state realization is to
flip a bit for every card that was drawn
now
what what we showed uh
in the paper um
was one that
uh there exists a guesser with only log
square n bits of memory
that plays very well when playing
against a random shuffle dealer
furthermore this guesser is
deterministic
so a simple adversarial argument can
tell that for every
deterministic guesser there exists a bad
ordering on which that getter managed to
make at most single correct guesses
guessing the last one correctly or a
single one a single card correctly may
be inevitable
so our second result is that there also
exists a guesser with
log square and bits of memory that plays
very well
against any static dealer
and like very well i mean very close to
lun m to a guesser with perfect memory
our third result shows that the above
are optimal so no guess or with
significantly less memory can play can
achieve similar results basically
and our fourth result
is an adaptive dealer
basically that defeats any guesser any
memory bounded guesser
so
the best a guesser can do
is just to focus on a subset of cards on
the the basic thing i showed in previous
slide
so the best guesser can do is to keep
cards in mind and hence the name
of the paper
while
we count the number of random bits used
by our first two guessers low memory
guessers
our
two impossibility results holds even
when the guesser has crypto and
unlimited randomness and is
computationally unbounded
the way we do it is uh by using a
technique called proof by encoding which
is quite general and successful method
um
some notable examples uh were
moser and talgo algorithmic level
and
proof for
the success rate of cuckoo hushing and
also in oracle separation in crypto
and basically uh
main ingredient for this technique is to
have an encoding decode functions for
some domain
and basically what we do is construct
these functions using the uh to guess
the two guessing functions that
the guesser is made of
the first mathematical piece we found on
card guessing comes from a paper by a
famous statistician ronald fisher from
1924
in the proceeding of the society of
psychical research where he suggested
and analyzed card guessing
as a method
to settle one's claim for having uh
clear clairvoyance or telepathy
abilities
but also a more decent research was
conducted uh even
lately
our work joins a tree of works
concerning adversarial streams in that
we show that
uh there exists a streaming problem
against which
adversarial
an adaptive adversary
basically can
can defeat
an algorithm
um we think it may be interesting to
look into the cases where the card is
made also from several copies of some of
the cards
um
and also in the case where the guests
are in the dealer change places and the
dealer is the one with limited memory
we also think it may be interesting to
think about
practical
usage of our technique maybe for
blackjack or poker
it seems very fit to finish
uh with george santayana's quote
those who cannot remember the past are
condemned to repeat it
and we add that this holds even if you
use randomness and cryptography
so thank you for listening and thank you
for the organizers
okay thanks that was a very interesting
thought if there are any questions uh
please type them in the chat and
um you can also just raise your hand and
i can
try to spot you and ask you to just say
them out loud
um
another thing uh the questions already
come in but another thing is jan can you
try and start uh sharing your slides so
that we don't have a break between the
two tops
[Music]
okay so the first question is uh do you
think your techniques could adapt to
lower bounds for some streaming problems
in adversarial settings
so
um
basically uh i think the answer is yes
but it depends what you consider as
lower bound
because it it's like it depends how you
look at it if you're talking about
impossibility results then yes
that's exactly what we do in the
uh in the paper
so definitely and uh if you want to
discuss
more
specific problem i'll be happy to
discuss it
later
okay i also have a great question maybe
just
how crucially does your result depend on
the charts being distinct in the data
maybe i tell you that one card appears
twice what will change
right that's an excellent question um so
i
went over this very briefly
there is the case where there are
several copies of the cards that's the
case i think you're talking about so our
algorithm doesn't scale well with the
number of copies
and in fact um
in
if there are too many copies our uh
algorithm performed even worse than a
memory-less algorithm
so i think that's a great open direction
uh to go into
okay oh so thanks for the talk uh for
the future talks if there are any
questions you can also put them in the
chat during the talk and um i will see
if i can interrupt this feature and if
not i'll just take them at the end
so the next feature is yand from
stanford
and he will be talking about a gaussian
fixed point random water
so give me one second apparently adobe
wasn't working which is
weird
okay um
uh does this work
we see our thumbnails on the left
uh yeah i'm not sure how to remove those
sorry
maybe dodu uh there's a three bars on
the top left
yeah okay
okay thank you thank you
um okay uh can i get started
okay uh so hey everyone i'm yong and
today i'm going to be presenting work on
a gaussian fixed point random walk this
is joint work with ashwin-san and
bethabsani at mit
so before talking about a gaussian fixed
point random walk i'm going to introduce
the problem which was the
motivating problem for this work
the problem studied is online vector
balancing
where
vectors v1 through vt which are
n-dimensional arrive one at a time
our goal is to assign signs epsilon 1 to
epsilon t
each of which is plus or minus 1 to
maintain a small discrepancy in other
words we want to keep the quantity
max over all prefixes
of the signed partial sum that vector uh
the elementary number that vector is
small
in general discrepancy theory has had
numerous applications including uh
balancing covariates in randomized
controlled trials
and online envy minimization
in general algorithmic discrepancy has
been a very active field since about 10
years ago bonsall and lovett mecca gave
a polynomial time algorithm to compute
uh
signings for the six standard deviation
suffice result dispenser
just to get some intuition for how an
online vector balancing procedure can go
um in the procedure we first get a
vector and then we assign it a sign and
then we maintain the partial sum
then we get an x then we get the next
vector and then our algorithm has to
assign a sign and then we update the
partial sum and we keep going
as you see
in this process the algorithm has to
take the input vector and assign a sign
before seeing the next vector
so in that sense it's more general than
the
offline discrepancy problems where you
get all the vectors immediately
for the purposes of this talk we're
going to focus on the case where all the
vectors are bounded in l2 norm
additionally we're going to assume an
oblivious adversary
in this setting all the vectors b 1
through v t are fixed beforehand and do
not change based on the randomness of
the algorithm
however the algorithm still has to
um
assign the sign epsilon i before seeing
the next vector v i plus one
so
as mentioned this model generalizes the
offline setting where all the vectors v
i are
revealed at the beginning and we get to
assign the signs after looking at all
the vectors
finally the oblivious adversary model is
a natural model because for
adaptive adverse series you can show a
square root t lower bound
and that's because what the adversary
can do is pick the next vector vi plus
one to be orthogonal
to the current partial sum maintained so
then the l2 norm of the vector will go
up by one every step no matter what our
algorithm does
to put our results in context it's
useful to mention some previous results
so
one benchmark we can compare previous
results against is this komlosh
conjecture which is an open problem in
mathematics
the combo's conjecture asks whether
given vectors v one through v t in n
dimensions
all with the l two number most one
whether there exists signs
to get the l infinity norm of the signed
partial sum of this all the signs of the
sign sum to be a constant
there's additionally a even stronger
version of this which is well what i'm
going to call the conlose conjecture for
prefixes
which asks given vectors b1 through vt
and n dimensions
all with l two not almost one
whether there are signs that actually
make all l infinity norms of all partial
sums of all prefixes a constant
so both of these are open it's not known
whether they're true
however the following results are known
you can show an upper bound of square
root log t
for the prefix version this is a result
due to venous chick
however banashik's result does not run
in polynomial time it's non-constructive
in terms of polynomial time algorithms
it's known how to achieve a square root
log t bound for the total sum but not
all prefixes
and finally
it's known how to achieve an o of log t
bound for prefixes
i think you can show this
using results of bunsal or low bet mecca
but additionally
um
if you design an online algorithm it
will naturally get a discrepancy bound
for all prefixes and that's um
the best known you can get an o of log
t-bone for all prefixes in an online
manner
towards um
these towards these uh problems here's
our results
so
while we don't
show the
maybe dream or optimal version of this
which is an o of square root log t bound
for all prefixes
in an online setting we do show the
following
um
so we show that in the combo setting so
this is where all the vectors have l2 or
most one
and they arrive in an online manner
we give an online algorithm against
oblivious adversaries
and we assign signs
of either -1 0 or
and very few of the signs are zero so at
most four percent of the signs are zero
and we achieve a discrepancy of square
root log t with high probability
so
uh square root log t is kind of like the
um description that you expect from
banashi expound
however our
algorithm
outputs some zero signs four percent of
the time so it doesn't actually get all
the way there
and um
in our second result we show that
there's an online algorithm against the
glibi's adversaries
that select signs either minus one one
or two that also achieves this gravity
square root of t so once again it
doesn't
only assign signs minus one one as you
would expect for a discrepancy problem
but it assigns a possible extra sign but
it achieves the square root log t
discrepancy
so
just a couple corollaries or discussion
so using the first result on partial
colorings you can recover an o of log t
back for online discrepancy by just
recoloring
the um signs that were assigned zero
so as noted
this falls short of matching monastics
found online and for all prefixes
because of the additional zero or two
signs allowed
however i think these results have made
us much more optimistic that a square
root log t online or prefix discrepancy
with polynomial runtime like only plus
minus one sign kind of this like dream
or optimal result uh we do believe it's
achievable with ideas along the same
lines but
we're not really able to analyze the
algorithms that
we're trying to design
okay
so
um now let me describe how we achieve
these results and
we achieve these results by designing a
random walk which might be independently
interesting which we call the gaussian
fixed point walk
what we precisely show it is that there
is a markov chain on r
whose steps are minus one zero one or
minus one one two
and there's almost a four percent
probability of picking zero each step
and the stationary distribution is
exactly the normal distribution in one
dimension so this is all one dimensional
from this we can design an online
discrepancy algorithm in the following
way
we
let's consider just the case where all
the vectors of l2 norm 1
so what we do is we initialize a
starting vector from the n-dimensional
normal distribution
so when vi arrives by we decompose the
n-dimensional normal distribution into
one-dimensional gaussians in the
direction of vi
and then we simulate the gaussian fixed
point random walk on that one direction
and we update the vector accordingly
to show that this works
uh all you need to show is that um the
distribution of the partial sum wi is
exactly normally distributed each step
therefore our partial sum is the
difference of two
possibly coupled gaussians with
distribution and zero i
and therefore the infinity norm is
square root log t with high probability
i wanted to discuss why we need this
extra zero sign
and the reason is because we can
actually show that there's no markov
chain on z so one dimension with steps
minus one one whose stationary is
exactly proportional to the gaussian
to show that
uh if such a chain existed then the
total mass on the even integers and odd
integers has to be the same but that's
that's not true so um that's why we
can't just we don't know how to design a
walk with minus one one and we need this
extra zero
okay
so let me just wrap up um there's
several
relationships to previous works i'm just
going to put up here but not really
discuss
so in terms of future directions um i'm
wondering obviously if we can design a
square root log t discrepancy bound with
signs minus one one for all prefixes
online etc
or even easier can you design a
polynomial times square root log t to
graph rebound for all prefixes even in
an offline setting
and finally are there other applications
of this gaussian fixed point walk
yeah uh that's all i had
okay thanks yan if there are any
questions uh please feel free to put
them in the chat or just raise your hand
uh in the meantime
uh luca maybe you can share your stream
i was curious um you wanted to get a
result without any zeros but you get
like four percent
of the zeros does it affect any of the
applications
um
so
in general in discrepancies here at this
point it's come down to being very
careful about getting the number of log
factors right
i think for a lot of especially after um
these results unlike recent results on
oblivious online discrepancies so in
that sense
yeah it's like doesn't get the number of
log factors correct
i haven't looked into applications
beyond that but
okay
interesting okay um thanks again the
next feature is luca from the university
of bad
and he will be speaking about geometric
bounce at the fastest missing markov
chain
[Music]
thanks for the introduction
so this is joint work with sam oleska
taylor also from the university of bath
so let me introduce
what is the fastest mixing markov chain
problem
as input we have a finite graph
undirected and our goal is to sample
from the uniform distribution over the
vertex set of this graph
and the common strategy to do so is to
construct a markov chain
on the vertical set of a g that has a
uniform invariant distribution
and that sort of respects the topology
of the graph
and with this i mean that the
transitions between states are allowed
only across edges of the graph
and for this algorithm to be as fast as
possible
we would like the mixing time of this
macro chain to be also as fast as
possible
[Music]
so let me be just a little bit more
formal
we can
formalize the fastest mixing uh time on
a graph as a minimization problem where
we are minimizing overall transition
matrices over the vertex set of the
graph that have a uniform invariant
distribution and that respects the
locality the topology of the graph
and
when i will be talking about mixing time
and we will
always be talking about the total
variation mixing time
and this problem has been introduced by
boy diacon essential in
o4 but there has been a few words since
however all this work focus mainly on
finding
alternative formulations of the problem
or finding relaxation for the problem or
even like
studying specific classes of grasses
such as the fastest in markov chain on a
path
what we want to do is something a little
bit
more general in my view in the sense
that we would like to characterize
what kind of graphs are made fast mixing
and our first main result essentially
shows that
vertex conductance characterizes fastest
mixing of a graph
so let me introduce the notion of vertex
conductance
given a subset s of vertices its vertex
conductance is just the ratio between
the
vertex boundary of the set divided by
the size of the set
and we can define the vertex conductance
of the whole graph as the minimum vertex
conductance of a set of vertices of the
graph
uh what we show is
essentially a
trigger type result that relates the
fastest mixing time on a graph uh to uh
to its vertex conductance in particular
we showed that the fastest mixing time
is sandwiched between the inverse of the
vertex conductance and the inverse
of the vector's conductance squared
times a polylog factor
and
if you remember children inequality
essentially says that the
mixing time of the simple random walk is
uh
related uh to the edge conductance of
the graph so we have something similar
but instead now we are considering not
the mixing time of a specific work of a
specific chain but the fastest mixing
time of all
chain and
its relation to the vertex conductance
of the graph
so let me just show you briefly an
example here we have two clicks
connected by a perfect matching
clicks of n vertices
the simple random walk mixed poorly on
this graph it takes all the movement
time to mix
however the vertex conductance of this
graph is almost optimal is a constant
independent of n and indeed also the
fastest mixed time is a constant and how
do we show that well essentially you
just need to consider
a
a simple random work on a rewriting of
the original graph where essentially we
have operated
the um
the edges between the two clicks
okay let me just say two words about the
proof so
the starting point of the proof is to
relax our problem instead of optimizing
for the
mixing time
we optimize for the spectral gap of the
transition matrix as a proxy of the
mixing time
and
it turns out that this
optimization problem
can actually be recast as a
semi-definite program and so we can
apply duality and we can obtain this
variational characterization that was
uh
say discovered by r
and i don't want to go into the details
of this i just want to highlight the
fact that this is the minimization of
our two functions
g and f
however
if we fix
the function f what we obtain is just a
linear program
and
this linear programming is actually the
2lp for
a fractional matching problem
on a graph that is obtained from the
original graph g
uh
by reweighting
the edges
in a particular way
and this prompt us to introduce this new
concept that we call a matching
conductance
it's uh its definition is similar to the
vertex conductance however here we are
not counting the vert expander of the
set what we are counting is we take the
set s
and we look at the edges between uh s
and its complement and we compute the
maximum weight matching over the edges
and what we show is essentially a
trigger type inequality that relates the
optimal spectral gap
uh to this uh matching conductance of
the graph
so what does this have to do with the
vertex conductance well it turns out
that matching the vertex conductance
are um
are the same
apart from up to a constant they are of
the same order so if you prove a trigger
type inequality for one you obtain a
trigger type inequality for the other
so now you will ask but why introduce
the
matching conductance in the
first place why not using
the vertex conductance directly well the
reason is that yes globally matching
inverted conductance are of the same
order however if you look at the
specific set s the matching conductance
of s might be
much smaller than the vertex conductance
of s
and so to apply the
uh let's say trigger machinery you
actually need
to uh exploit this matching conductance
and this essentially
what i wanted to say about uh the proof
of this result
so essentially afternoon what we have
shown is that
um
before before you proceed there is a
question have you thought about getting
a tighter bound on the mixing time by
bounding the modified large troublelift
processing of the water instead of the
spatula
i didn't think about it that much in the
sense that it
came to my mind but
i guess we exploit this uh
sdp duality
and uh
i don't know can you
i'm not sure you can
recast
log sublime as an stp but maybe you can
and in the case you
you might obtain but i think what you
would
you would get is still yeah you would
get still instead of
i don't think it would have that much to
be honest because
we lose a factor of logan
[Music]
because of an application of johnson
linda strauss
and then the other logan factor it's
sort of needed because in
trigger
type results it's needed when you bound
mixing time
and so
you would have the same
i think
bound with respect to the vertex
conductance
but i'm not sure i don't know if that
makes sense
okay
okay thanks for the question
okay so uh yeah uh where was i so uh
yeah so essentially we've shown that um
to have
to admit fast mixing a graph needs to
have a relatively large
vertex conductance
uh
so
so we sort of ask ourselves
can we actually
obtain a fast mixing markov chain
on a graph with small vectors
conductance
if we relax a bit
the
the requirement of the uh fastest mixing
markov chain problem
and uh
the answer is yes by uh considering the
following
relaxation instead of asking for our
market chains to
mix
precisely to the uniform distribution
what we ask is for uh our markov chain
to be to uh
to have a
an invariant distribution that is
epsilon clause
in total variation distance to the
uniform distribution
and then we show that it's always
possible to construct such a chain that
mixes in time that essentially depends
uh quadratically on the diameter and
this
might be
much better
than the vertex conductance bound
an example the dumbbell graph
two clicks of n vertices connected by
single edge here the vertex conductance
is quite poor is a more than one over n
and so the fastest mixing uh is also
order of n however if you look at the
diameter the diameter is a very small is
just constant
and
indeed you can
construct a chain that
mixes in time that is
essentially independent on n
and you do that by considering a
spanning tree
of the graph
carefully relate this spanning tree and
then perform a symbol and walk on this
three weighted graph
okay so uh let me uh conclude
um
what we have shown essentially is that
three geometric quantities characterize
the mixing properties of the graph it
was already known by children equality
that
edge conductance characterize the
mixing time of the simple random work
what we've shown is that the ventral
conductance characterize the fastest
mixing time on the graph while the
diameter characterizes the fastest
almost mixing time of the graph
there are several
questions left open by our work
i just want to mention one
this relation between edge conductance
and the mixing time of the simple random
work has been
quite fruitful from an algorithmic point
of view
can our results also spur some
algorithmic
result
we are not sure but we would like to
find out
thank you very much
okay thanks for the talk uh demetrius
maybe you can start sharing your screen
and if there are any questions for luka
feel free to ask them
hi
hi yeah john
so so
you mentioned the johnson thing that
lama so do you think that you can
replace
gl with a different cap and batting to
improve the long end dependency
yeah
essentially the problem is that you can
you might be able to improve
uh and get rid of the logan factor but
you can only get
uh
you cannot get rid
altogether of this
factor in the sense that you need a log
of the
maximum degree of the graph at least
otherwise uh something called the small
set expansion uh conjecture would be
wrong and this would be like a quite uh
i don't know if unexpected but like
uh
we right now we don't know how to prove
or disprove this uh
small set expansion conjecture so i
think a log
d-max
maximum degree factor is
needed
do you know what is the contractual
mixing time it does
not need to be lost log n square or is
that expected to be lower than log n
square
okay so
there should be a log demax in the
relation with the spectra gap
and then we get a login factor because
when you go from the spectral gap to the
mixing time you lose the logan factor
right well i say if you can bow the msi
constant then
to go from ls i think maybe
i think maybe remaining questions can be
taken offline oh yeah yeah sorry more
speakers
okay so the next feature is dimitrios
from the university of cambridge and
you'll be talking about balance
allocations within complete information
[Music]
yes uh thank you uh so my name is
dimitri slos uh i will be presenting
balanced allocations with incomplete
information the power of two queries
this is joint work with thomas zarwald
from the university of cambridge
so we'll start with some background on
balanced allocation process in
particular sequential balanced
allocation process
so we are given m tasks or balls and we
need to sequentially allocate them into
n machines or bins
and the goal is to minimize the maximum
load so in this load configuration the
maximum load is just five
and minimizing the maximum load is
equivalent to minimizing the gap the gap
is the distance of the maximum load to
the mean
so in a centralized setting this problem
is trivially solved using round robin
allocation but in decentralized settings
we look for a process that assumes
coordination between the bins
and this finds applications in hashing
load balancing and routing
so the simplest of these process is the
one choice process
so for each ball you pick a bin unit for
me at random and you allocate the ball
there
it is well known that in the lightly
loaded case that is when the number of
balls is equal to the number of beams
the gap is log n over log log n
with high probability and here with high
probability mean probability at least
one minus n to the minus c for some
positive constant c
in the heavily loaded case that is when
the number of balls is many much more
than the number of beans
then the gap is square root m over n
times log n
so you can think about this as the
maximum of n independent poisson random
variables
a great improvement is the two choice
process where for each ball we sample
two bins uniformly at random and we
place in the least loaded of the two
bins
in the lightly loaded case this process
has a log log n gap
so this is approximately an exponential
speed up over one choice
in the heavily loaded case the
improvement is even more dramatic
because the gut bound remains the same
with high probability
and there is no dependence on m
there are several other processes like
the oneplus beta process which
interpolates between two choice and one
choice with probability beta
myth and mather interpreted this process
as um
two choice where uh when making their
comparison there is a probability of
making an error
and perestalter invader proved that in
the heavy loaded case the process has a
gap of logan over beta when beta is
sufficiently large and bounded away from
one
uh
our results also imply
tighter gaps for when beta is close to
one so when we are doing
most of the time to choice
so let's look at the process we focus on
our work
so the first process is the
adaptive one threshold process
so based on the entire load distribution
we pick a threshold
then we sample a bin if the bin is below
has a load that is below the threshold
then we allocate there
otherwise we pick another being
uniformly at random and we allocate
there
of course the second bean could be worse
than the first one
uh and feldheym and gurukevich
determined the optimal threshold for the
lightly loaded case and they showed the
gap of square root log n over log log n
with high probability
they also conjectured that this gap
bound holds in the heavily loaded case
also it was recently shown that in the
heavily loaded case when the threshold
is equal to the mean
then the process achieves a log n gap
a very related process is the one
quantile process
so based on the entire load distribution
instead of picking a threshold we pick a
quantile
then if the bin sampled is above the
quantile then we allocate the ball there
otherwise we allocate randomly
and it's easy to see that the adaptive
quantile process can simulate any
adaptive threshold process
and it's also possible to see that if we
mix two adaptive threshold process then
we can simulate any quantile process
and both of these are special cases of
two thinning where we pick a decision
criteria of whether to accept the bin
based on the entire history of the
process
and there are extensions of two thinning
where you take up to these samples and
you have a decision criteria of whether
to accept a bin or reject it
and one another different way to
interpret one threshold process is as to
choice with incomplete information
so when we pick the threshold we can
only distinguish two bins if
one is below the threshold and the other
one is above
so these two means we can distinguish
these two beans we cannot and these two
bins we cannot distinguish
and there is a similar interpretation
for one quantile but now the regions are
in the rank space
so if one is above the quantile and one
the other one is below then we can
distinguish otherwise we cannot
and based on this interpretation
we can split the load space in more
regions for example if we use two
thresholds we split the load space in
three regions and we can only
distinguish two beans if they're in
different regions
so these two beans are in different
regions
and these two beans are in the same
region so we cannot distinguish
and
you woman kawashi showed that uh in the
analyze the lightly loaded case where
when we're using equidistant thresholds
but in our work we mostly focus on the
heavily loaded case
and it's also possible to do this for k
quantiles splitting the the rank space
in in more regions
uh so our results um
the the first one was
to disprove the conjecture by feldheym
and guerillage and show that
any adaptive one quantile or one
threshold process
has a gap that is omega log n over log
log n in the first n log squared n
rounds
and on the positive side we introduce
the k quantile process uh where the
quantiles are independent of the load
distribution and this achieves a k times
log n to the one over k
gap
so for k equals one
we have a log n upper bound
for k equals two we have a square root
log n upper bound
and because of the
of the lower bound that we have
uh
this difference here we term as the
power of two queries so this almost
quadratic speed up
and then if we take k equals three we
get
uh cube root of log n and then fourth
root of log n and it approximates two
choice in particular for
k being log log n we recover the two
choice upper bound on the gap
up to multiplicative
constant factors
also uh by majorization we're able to
analyze the oneplus beta when beta is
very close to one in particular when
beta is one minus polyen then the gap is
also log log n
and by measurization we also hand uh
introduce
an adaptive de-thinning process which
achieves similar
gap bounds
furthermore we are able to analyze two
choice in graphical allocations in dense
expander graphs and prove a log logan
gap and this makes progress towards the
second open question by perestal variant
leader
finally we think our results might be
useful for analyzing other randomized
processes
in particular we use layered induction
over super exponential potential
functions um so just a brief overview
of what this is uh so perestal and
leader use the hyperbolic cosine
potential
which basically has an exponential term
for each for the normalized load and for
the negative normalized load and this is
smoothed by a factor alpha
so in the one plus beta process alpha is
theta of beta
and peristal can leader prove that on
any possible load configuration this
potential
drops when it is sufficiently large
and by using induction and the entire
law of expectation one can show that the
expectation of the exponential potential
is at most c times n where c depends on
c one and c two
and then using marcos inequality one can
get an upper bound on the gap by noting
that each of these terms must be
strictly positive so and the gap we get
is log n over alpha so when alpha is
small it is easier to prove the drop but
the gap bound is worse
and they they use alpha that's at most a
constant so the tightest gap bonds they
they could obtain were log n
so in our work we use super exponential
potential functions which basically
means that alpha can be super constant
however the decrease does not follow at
any step arbitrarily so we have to
condition
on a smaller super exponential potential
being linear
and and for this we develop a technique
which might be general so if you have
a linear expectation on a exponential
potential function
then how to convert this into a high
probability result
and there are several
open questions like what are the lower
bounds for adaptive k quantile process
is it possible to prove similar bounds
for the k threshold process
and is it possible to analyze the two
choice process in different noise
conditions
so thank you very much for listening
thank you we can maybe squeeze one
question while the next feature sets up
um so i guess we have um
none
i had one question uh that i
uh that came to my mind when i read the
abstract it seems that
the improvements are
very
fine they are about lot factors and
sometimes doubly logistic factors do you
have something to say on this is it
really crucial to have these uh
what is your opinion on this
um
you mean between uh one quantile and two
quantiles
um
uh actually i meant something like the
previous best known versus your result
uh so the previous best known you mean
was in the lightly loaded case
in our work we mostly focused on the
heavily loaded case which is
for arbitrary and i see then maybe i
maybe i remember the likelihood case
okay thanks
um so our next feature is june from
stanford and she'll be talking about
domain specification of distributed
distributions using anthropic
independence
i uh
thank thank yahu fans for the
introduction so this year i worked with
my father nima nari at stanford we
called in ski at
uc berkeley i think a little bit in the
in the audience
so
so i will start with a
motivating uh example problem for for
this work so so consider this problem of
a sampling from an element
uh from 1 to n even some weights b 1 to
p n
uh so that so that the probability of
output the element i is proportional to
pi
so here's an illustration
with the blue column represent pi
so there's a missing
pattern function to do this
this function has a
optional element called cumulative
weight
which is the array where the element
whether j element is the sum of p i for
i going from one to j
so with cumulative weight we can reduce
the
sampling time from
order n to other log n
so say um if you want to provide k
sample from this
problem then you can first compute the
cumulative weight
in time or the end and then you can
produce a subsequent sample in other
entire
daytime lock end
so
the the the wisdom from this is that we
can produce samples in
a much faster almost high run time using
this
trick of like computing the cumulative
way first
so now our question is
can we do the same
for
other distribution that has exponential
support size so remember this
institution has a support side just and
so we can always pre-compute this area
of community weight
but what about
distribution that that has a very large
support
so the a concrete way to formulate this
problem is like um so consider this
uh so say you are given a discrete
distribution mu
that is a distribution uh over psi k
subset of a graph set
of size n and you're going to use a
sample a prop approximately sample for
mu
and by approximately example i mean to
produce a sample from a distribution mu
prime that is close to mu interval t
resistance
so the question is how much time do we
need to produce uh one sample for mu
and in general you shouldn't expect to
to get uh faster than like n choose k
time because what if mu is support on
just one element then it takes you like
end to skate time to
even find this element right
but we i hope with that line
for certain family of mew and then after
some pre-processing step we can reduce
the domain size that is the size of the
ground set from n to some
set t of sine was stronger than n and
then we get in program time for
something for mu
so this framework of reducing amortized
sampling time through pre-processing is
very useful for counting problems
um
because for counting problems we have
this
time framework where we need to
repeatedly sample from move to
um to say
estimate the support side of me
okay so example distribution where this
domain specification framework has had
proven to be useful include um
the distribution over spanning trees of
forest or over a fixed side matching
of a graph
and
something called determinant to a point
process so
so to remind
people of some basic graph theoretic
definition a spanning tree of a graph is
a set of edges that form a connected and
loopless subgraph
of the original graph so here the orange
edges form a spanning tree of this
of this
seven vertices graph and
a k matching is a set of k uh edges in
the graph so that no two edges set the
same endpoint so here the orange edge
formula two matching
um and determinant also the the
distribution that we care about in this
case are the uniform distribution over
spanning tree or over um fixed imagine
the graph
determinant of process is the
generalization of these uniform
distribution over spanning tree and over
fixed side matching so
um
a k determinant
process in the fiber matrix l
upside n by n where the probability of a
set x is proportional to the
minor um of the sub matrix index by s
so here like when x is the same one two
four then the probability of this set s
is proportional to the
determinant of the submatrix column in
red here
so the traditional focus
with dppr on
matrix although are symmetric so l
equals l transpose but recently people
have started to study non-symmetric
matrix and for their enhanced modeling
power
and and more
determine the possible set with
symmetric
matrix a and non-symmetric matrix
are useful for many applications
including
a recommended system in machine learning
image search and generally in random
linear entrepreneur and you can look at
this reference to to file to far more
application of determination by process
so i will uh briefly study background
our
like of our work
so this this framework of the main
specification
start with a work by nehrunski and uh
and calendar trial lawrenceville and
vancouver
where they apply this framework for
sampling from symmetric determinate
employ process
and then uh last year there was a
false paper by uh nima and mikhail
who uh
is found this book to sample from on log
content distribution
um so
our work triangle lies these two
previous works by um expanding
uh to the
to the class of entropy independent
distribution
and this class uh include on the
distribution considered as in previous
school and in the additional also
include the
distribution over
fixed side matching and
uh distribution on non-symmetric
determinant point process
the notion of entropy independence were
introduced last year by
lima myself and some other co-authors it
turned out to be the right
definition for this domain specification
framework
so we will first define what is entropy
independence
so for distribution mu
define the
generating polynomial polynomial of mu
to be the polynomial over
n variable z1 to zn that is the sum of
mu s time product of the i for i in s so
think of this polynomial f mu as a way
to extend the
regimen mu to the uh to the r to the n
support
what's up um so our distribution is
called enterprise independent if the
charity polynomial of mu
applied by some deformation is up about
by
uh the tangent at one of this
transformation
and now we're ready to state our main
result so
we say that when the distribution bill
is one over i'm trying to be independent
then basically we can always reduce the
task of something from
domain upside n here to the main upside
n raised to one minus alpha and he uses
thing of alpha as some as some constant
between zero and one for example alpha
can be one half or one
uh the application of this theorem
include
a very fast algorithm to either sample
from or
tell the support of a variable
distribution that are discussed so we
have first algorithm to cal psi k
matching implano graph
so and here that is a number of vertices
in the graph so this is
actually a
sub
something here for lens graph
and we have fast algorithm to
sample from non-symmetric kdpp
um
and
for symmetric kdpp we actually had some
subsequent work that take some idea from
this book and improve the the
run the the sampling time and the
pre-processing time to be
practically optimal
and more generally we found that like
for any distribution after
pre-processing we can always reduce
domain size from n to n raised to one
minus one over k
and this actually match the birthday
part of threshold so if you think of
distribution over side to subset then we
only reduce the domain side from n to
square root n
and we cannot we know that we cannot do
better because uh if we reduce to below
zero and we may not even get any
set in the support of the restriction at
all
so
so conclusion is that our work
generalized and improved on the
previous work by nima and nikon
and we found that the entry independence
is a minimal assumption for
the domain specification framework to do
to succeed and we also have thai lower
bound construction for the side of the
domain
there's some open problem about
reducing the
the
um
about reducing the sampling time for the
uh for a
more restricted class of a fractionally
log concave distribution
uh and but this time it still includes
all the
distribution that i previously discussed
and if we can
obtain this then we would get
more efficient algorithm for this
problem of something from
non-semitic dpp and other related
distribution related to
determined to apply process
and this will also be another way to
channelize the
previous work by nima and nicole
because that's the end of my talk thanks
for listening
um
thank you i have a question i understand
the birthday paradox found uh so that
says that you don't get better than n to
the one minus one or k
but
um can you also say what is stopping you
from applying your transformation twice
first i get two n to the 1 minus alpha
and then i do it again to get something
smaller
[Music]
so
so
hmm
um so i
i think the problem with this is like
after you reduce domain size to end to
one minute one hour pay you just don't
get an instrument at all so if it's like
when you reduce for the first time you
when you get one minus one over with the
one minus one over k you may get a
distribution that only have one
uh one set in the support
like like the data is distributed uh
over a single set s in the in in in in
contained in n to the one minus one over
k so
i i i i guess then the task would
you you no matter how you want to
classify you need to first find set x
like
um
it just doesn't make a lot of sense to
to think about like specifying it
further when your distribution of like
is to the point that it
is a single atom distribution wait but
if it's only one set why don't i just
remove everything that's not in the set
and
yeah yeah the same thing you have
learned everything about the
distribution right like
you probably know everything other
distribution so what so so if you can
remove everything outside the set then
you already know what it should look
like so maybe you don't need to
uh pre-processing for the you you just
output the single sentence like in your
distribution
so so so yeah i think you're right like
you can always radically reduce to size
uh to like a distribution of size
i like to to to a domain of size k
by
by just specifying to this point and
then find out the
only single useful set
uh but i guess this this part is more
like um
like a general comment
i think this this um
this the main specification for
from one to one minus one okay it's not
so useful
because
like
uh so i think it's become too general
that like after you reduce to end raise
the one reason overpay sometimes you
cannot sometimes the problem of
something from this distribution
become very hard like exponentially hard
so that the gain you get from this
pre-processing step is not
meaningful
i think you should focus more on the
the
case where you have an amphi entry
independence with alpha around like some
constant
and then you will get like
uh sufficiently
like you get like n to the raise to the
one minus time for uh domain size and
then you will get actual gain in
in your sampling uh in your sampling
time compared to this
okay
thank you uh so they were all great dots
let's stand the speakers one more time
i'm sorry we went a little over time but
that only happens when the dots are
interesting so it's a good sign
okay um thank you that's this session
see you the remainder of the conference